a heavy-duty hand cannon with an
imposing title and a big bang to match
feels good
sounds good the desert eagle is one of
the most famous handguns in history it's
found in the arsenal of many a movie
villain and video game gunslinger but
it's actually
seldom seen in the real world so how did
a gun that sees almost no serious use
gets so much pop culture attention i've
come to the royal armouries museum in
the uk to find out why the des eagle
might not have been the all-conquering
weapon that games and movies would have
you believe let's lock and load
[Music]
the desert eagle was designed by u.s
company magnum research between 1979 and
1982 with the aim of creating a high
caliber handgun at this point in firearm
history if you were after a sidearm that
packed a punch in the palm of your hand
you were limited to revolvers later
design work was refined by israeli
military industries or imi for short who
also worked on the desert eagles mass
production this combined effort between
manufacturers resulted in the desi eagle
mark 1 with their work allowing for this
new mammoth gas-operated pistol to be
chambered in multiple large calibers
namely the 357 and 44 magnum at the time
of its introduction in 1983 the desert
eagle was unlike any other handgun on
the market and with the introduction of
the even larger caliber of 50 action
express in future models the desert
eagle would further push the limits of
how much power a handgun could unleash
many of you watching this may have seen
this weapon appear in games and other
media under a different name but still
with the iconic .50 adorning its title
from the d50 the nighthawk 50c and the
50gs an iconic part of the weapon is a
nod to its high power and caliber but
when it comes to this handheld 50 cal
what does the term actually mean we have
to differentiate between what the word
calibre actually means
which is the internal diameter of the
barrel of a firearm which obviously has
a direct relationship to the diameter of
the bullet and caliber as a sort of
synonym for cartridge type so 50 action
express that the desert eagle fires is a
cartridge type and it's a lot shorter
than
50 browning machine gun the difference
in size is is immense and two completely
level different levels of destructive
power as a result you might have a
similar mass similar diameter of
projectile but you're not propelling the
thing at anything like the same velocity
to fully appreciate what makes the
desert eagle so unique among handguns
and why it sees such limited real world
use we need to go back to the core of
its design there's a lot that sets the
desert eagle apart its distinctive
silhouette imposing shape often seen
shining in chrome or even an audacious
gold it's like
a
movie star a dirty herald but perhaps
the first thing many would notice is its
sheer size this thing is huge coming in
as standard in 10.75 inches in length
nearly three inches longer than the
standard glock 17. and with that size of
course comes weight the mark 1950 ae
version of the desert eagle weighs just
shy of 2 kilos or 4.4 pounds and that's
when the thing is empty while the size
and weight of the weapon are essential
to facilitate its operation the
distinctive design has become a
shorthand for powerful hand cannons in
many of our video games even within
unique fictional arsenals echoes of its
design or references to its power can be
seen inspiring video game weaponry like
halo's m6 series of magnums the
post-apocalyptic 10 millimeter pistol or
fallout 3 in new vegas or even as the
kramer 0.50 magnum in aliens fire team
elite
its considerable power even demands
respect when the hands holding it are
made from pixels and polygons and the
fact that it's almost always shown
firmly gripped in two hands is another
subtle nod to its sheer power a useful
visual indicator to players that the
sidearm in their possession is about to
throw out some heavy recoil soldiers and
special forces from call of duty
battlefield far cry and counter-strike
all model the weapon with this in mind
and even the larger-than-life characters
like sirius sam or max payne pay the
desert eagle due respect when it comes
to using their side up although that
wouldn't stop old max from flying
through the air duel wielding them in
both single and multiplayer games it's
frequently one of the last guns to
unlock or one of the most expensive ones
to purchase further creating an aura of
mystique or rarity to what is already
considered a skill cannon in most video
games but in spite of the high price for
entry or the long grind the desi eagle
often takes to unlock the reward isn't
always worth the effort commonly having
a slow rate of fire limited range and a
small magazine to balance its power the
desert eagle is often outside of a few
exceptions seldom seen in our
multiplayer battlefields however that
aspect is much closer to its real use
than you may first think despite its
reputation and massive pop culture
footprint that sees it featuring in over
600 films tv shows and video games the
desert eagle is actually used by well
almost no one officially we know that
the polish special forces grom have them
listed in their inventory of weapons and
the portuguese special operations group
have some access to the 357 versions of
the pistol but it's unclear whether
within these organizations the desert
eagles are for familiarization purposes
or as an actually issued sidearm so the
pistol's real world use may actually be
even more rare than we earlier assumed
so despite being the most powerful
handgun in the world it's not a power
that any organization or force in the
real world seems to be that interested
in harnessing i get asked quite a bit
whether there is any practical purpose
for something like a desert eagle the
answer is from a military and law
enforcement arguably even a self-defense
perspective there is no
real practical purpose for it it was
designed to be the biggest and best
in its class
and it it pulled that off there are
semi-practical uses for it certain parts
of the world from for example the united
states have hunting seasons so that
means there are handgun hunting seasons
and now obviously the most powerful
handgun you can lay your hands on
is desirable for hunting self-defense
against very large animals something
that can deliver an awful lot of energy
and stop the thing before it claws your
face off you can see how there might be
a use for that and the final actual real
world use is in target shooting even
then it's it's pretty niche within a
niche so in theory hunting target
shooting and really there it's about the
challenge of controlling the recoil of a
magnum handgun it's easy to see why it
hasn't caught on with the likes of
police military or special forces though
it is undoubtedly incredibly powerful
pure power isn't necessarily the most
appealing prospect for many tactical
situations even loaded with 357 the
desert eagle has less than half the
capacity of regular handguns not to
mention it's impractically big and the
concept of carrying that ridiculous
weight is no doubt an ugly one for any
soldier already weighed down with kits
and equipment not only that but it's
pricey the gun itself can sometimes cost
in excess of two thousand dollars and
can cost two to three dollars per round
pre-tax for 50 ae so it's loud flashy
powerful and expensive to put it simply
they only built it because they could as
with many larger-than-life firearms the
legacy of the desert eagle mostly rests
on the shoulders of its pop culture
impact
according to an article from the
baltimore sun magnum research were
actively soliciting prop houses to use
their gun in their films of course
weapons appearing in movies has always
been an avenue for manufacturers to
advertise their wares and grow their
brand but to me this shows that the
people behind the desert eagle were
always well aware of its image and
potential on the big screen and were
more than happy to allow it to become a
celebrity gun its appearance in the
hands of a huge spectrum of characters
means it has become an iconic weapon for
some of the most imposing characters but
by and large the personalities that have
taken the sidearm onto the silver screen
have given the desert eagle an air of
being a bad guy gun it's the weapon of
choice for bullet dodging agents in the
matrix movies including the latest
matrix resurrections and one of its most
famous video game appearances is pointed
directly down the camera towards the
player by khalid al-assad in call of
duty 4 modern warfare
it is flashy and overkill in more than
one sense meaning it also sits right at
home in the arsenals of the cockiest and
most showboating of characters be that
the mercenary sam serious stone or seen
in the hands of lo wang in the high
octane shadow warrior
in the hands of the traditional good guy
though the desert eagle is usually
reserved for the action hero whose
stature suits their large silver sidearm
whether that is john matrix in the
spectacular 1985 action movie commando
us marshal john kruger in the 1996
action thriller eraser or in the action
fantasy cult classic film within a film
last action hero wielded by the
formidable jack slater
there is something similar about these
guys though i've spoken to a number of
prop masters and armorers over the years
you have to pick something of a suitable
size and presence for the character so
that's in terms of their their
personality you know are they the big
action hero like arnie maybe they're the
villain like you know bullet tooth tony
desert eagle fits there as well
something like the desert eagle has so
much presence it's so physically large
that it still looks like a big gun even
though it's being held by a big guy how
is that guy
conor frase moving away from silver
screens and onto smaller ones one of its
most famous video game appearances is
also responsible for one of its most
common nicknames the deagle in 1999
counter-strike was born as a mod for the
game half-life and would make a full
release a year later after valve
acquired the team and the intellectual
property for those of you who are
unfamiliar with counter-strike it pits
two teams against each other in the
defending and taking of objectives like
hostages or bomb sites the pistol class
of course featuring the desert eagle
named in-game as the nighthawk .50c
although in all the entries of
counter-strike that i've played be that
the original cs source or global
offensive the deagle is the only name
you'll ever hear originally this pistol
was known by its full name but was
changed before counter-strike would
leave its beta branches but because of
this the files retained references to
their original names and titles and no
doubt to keep things nice and neat the
programmers simply shorten the file
names in the case of this pistol d eagle
but despite the name change players knew
exactly what this thing was and since cs
is a game about communication and
call-outs desert eagle doesn't exactly
roll off the tongue so the portmanteau
of deagle became the de facto name fans
gave to counter-strike's hand cannon
across the franchise and that nickname
is still used today the deagle already
had its share of fame from its time in
cinema but the success of counter-strike
meant a spotlight was cast on the game
and the weapon's virtual adaptation also
got a share of that attention from the
early 2000s the desert eagle became a
popular choice to diversify the
selection of sidearms in virtual
shooters it was a part of launching many
franchises that are still popular today
appearing in the first ever far cry game
the first max payne hitman codename 47
the first in that franchise the first
tomb raider featured a pair of 50 cal
pistols seen to be desi eagles in the
more graphically detailed anniversary
edition of the game and of course as
previously mentioned in call of duty 4
modern warfare anytime you need a weapon
that's big scary looking all those all
those sharp edges be that agents in the
matrix or the action hero it's just got
more presence compare it to
conan the barbarian sword your hero
sword has to be big and impressive it's
the same with the handgun and there
aren't that many giant handguns around
you either have to give them a big old
revolver or a deagle the desert eagle is
an iconic firearm whose life in popular
culture and reality are almost at polar
opposites the impact it's had on video
games movies tv shows and larger than
life action stories far outweighs its
real world use
which is probably for the best in movies
it's a weapon to add a sense of power
and intensity to a hero or villain in
games it's a sidearm to show off skill
or to diversify a player's weapon wheel
and in reality it's a team of engineers
pushing boundaries and a firearm for
enthusiasts range shooters and hunters
it completely falls short of the needs
of real world professional soldiers and
organizations but it's shown in those
exact situations and arsenals in our
fiction where pesky things like physics
weight recoil or logistics just don't
matter and that secures the fact that
the desert eagle's legacy is one that
has found a home in our imagination and
in our entertainment i do so love a good
firearm in my hand
i hope you enjoyed this episode of
loadout if you did hit the like button
subscribe for more like this and let me
know your thoughts either in the comment
section down below or reach out to me on
twitter at a regular day
let us know what you'd like to see
future episodes cover and if you want
more video game firearms content you can
watch previous episodes of the show or
check out our weekly series of firearms
expert reacts where i show our friends
the royal armories a selection of guns
from our favorite games until next time
i've been your host dave dewitt thank
you again for watching and i'll see you
in the next episode
[Music]
you